-Welcome to "Late Night,"
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How's everybody doing?
All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In that case,
let's get to the news.
I mean, those of us
who still can.
Fox News announced today
that it has parted ways
with host Tucker Carlson,
and last Friday
was his final show,
which is great
but also unsettling,
at least when he had a show,
we knew where he was.
It's creepy trying
to fall asleep
with a ventriloquist dummy
in your room,
but it's way creepier
when you wake up
and it's not there anymore.
"Huh, that's weird.
Oh, my God, is it behind me?"
Also today, CNN parted ways
with anchor Don Lemon
amid accusations
of sexist behavior.
Wow, does anybody have
an opening for a sexist?
Oh, right.
So that would...
President Biden is reportedly
preparing to formally announce
he is running for re-election.
If successful, he will be
the oldest man.
That's it, just the oldest --
just the oldest man.
That's right.
President Biden
is reportedly planning
to formally announce
his re-election campaign
as early as this week,
which is frankly a little crazy.
He's gonna be 82.
I think you should stop
running for president
when people start saying
"young" after your age.
Joe here, 82 years young.
Not only that, the leader of the
free world, that's pretty nuts.
President Biden met today
with three Tennessee lawmakers
who led gun safety protests
at the state capitol.
Meanwhile, Ron DeSantis
met with the guns.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Judiciary Chair
Dick Durbin, in a new interview,
called for a code of conduct
for Supreme Court justices,
because right now, the only rule
is no front flips off the yacht.
New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy
recently declared
that September 23rd
will be Bruce Springsteen Day,
as opposed to Jersey's previous
Springsteen Day -- all of them.
McDonald's has announced
it will offer
its Big Mac sauce on the side
for dipping or, what the hell,
soaking.
New York officials
unveiled a plan today
to install 10 miles of bike
lanes throughout the city.
That story again --
New York officials
are adding 10 more miles
of sometimes car lanes.
IKEA announced plans last week
to open up eight more stores
across the U.S.
or more likely will start
to build them,
get frustrated, and give up.
According to a new study --
We've all done that,
we've all done it.
According to a new study,
Americans over 50
who play video games
feel overlooked
by the gaming industry.
For example, there is no option
to play "Grand Theft Auto"
with your left blinker
on the whole time.
That's right,
70% of older Americans
who play video games
do not feel like products
are designed with them in mind,
because when they tried it,
they failed miserably.
[ Crowd murmurs ]
[ Laughter ]
And that's sadly because you
can't ever predict
the future was our final joke
of the monologue.
You try you usually try
to close on a banger
and sometimes you close
on one that goes like that.
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't matter, though,
because we've got a great show
for you tonight!